greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happening now is brought to
you by hymns listened hymns is a
wellness brand for men you've heard us
talking about him if you haven't yet get
on board and stop struggling with sexual
performance issues stop struggling with
losing your hair you know listen 1 in 4
guys suffer from IDI but it can be
treated okay
over 25% of new IDI cases the guys under
40 can you believe that I'm 56
still swinging dick and there's people
out there that under 40 and you're not
getting an erection why do guys turn to
weed solutions that do nothing things
that you buy it like some voodoo shop or
something like that when they can turn
to medicine and science this is why I
say to you go to four hymns calm right
now if you're struggling with IDI listen
for hymns is a one-stop shop for hair
loss skin care sexual wellness for men
you understand me don't get the fronted
by unlike sketchy marketplaces him for
hymns calm is the way to go so what the
church is gonna do is this this first
month is just five hours we'll get you
started for five hours while supplies
last and subject to doctor approval
restrictions apply so see the website
for details so do me a favor this could
cost you hundreds of hours if you went
to the doctor plus the embarrassing side
War hymns calm is nice and easy
you fill out what you got a doctor
lawyer and next thing you know boom you
get your prescriptions delivered right
do right there to your door
nobody knows nothing you understand me
so do me a favor go to four hems calm
slash Church again that's four hems calm
slash church for hems dot-coms last
church for hymns this is where you get
some help and while you taking care of
your IDI problems you also want to be
fresh and ready is why I come at you on
a Monday morning with this cuz that's a
company called manscape that'll take you
a little lower area to a new level you
understand me uncle Joey's here to tell
you you don't have to suffer no more
there's not gonna be a little stink with
manscape you got
done without the pain they got precision
tools for the family jewels you
understand me you want to keep those
goals and [ __ ] tremendous order you
don't want them to stink like billy
goats and stuff they got a lot more 2.0
they got this is a handheld razor with
skin safe technology so well Nick or
snag your nutsack or your little pinky
thing you understand me this bad boy
will leave you clean smooth and
pain-free ready to sling dick and put it
in somebody's anus you follow me and
it's rechargeable and it's easy to hold
see you can go to all the nooks and
crannies you ever opened up your [ __ ]
leg you filthy animal and you see all
those little hairs by your nutsack you
plow those down
they got another classic safety razor
called the plow you take all those hairs
not like a lick your balls lick your ass
for pleasure
no more Guinea smell no more [ __ ] and
you know listen I could I could blow
smoke up your ass but you know and I
know it it's time to keep that area
[ __ ] shiny go to manscape calm right
now and get everything you need to make
your balls shine and keep your dick
looking [ __ ] tremendous this is the
perfect package yeah understandable
listen listeners the church family can
get 20% off your first order when you
use code church at manscape calm and if
you don't order the perfect package
don't also throw in if you order the
perfect package go throw in a free
travel bag all right
that's manscape comm promo code church
for 20% off your first order wash your
balls [ __ ] it's Monday it's
gonna be a good [ __ ] week take
this meal Lee I can watch you dance all
day I love dancing oh I love all this
[ __ ] when I'm by myself
music yeah just putting it on nobody's
home I get those speakers on [ __ ]
laughs that's my neighbor's [ __ ] the
neighbors yeah okay this is why you got
a backyard and you [ __ ] rip it up I
love music and I love dancing this old
[ __ ] I love it mm-hmm what's that baby
oh I'm just happy to see you I would
see you and then you just disappear from
I was telling you before when you came
in that one they were at the store
listen my favorite thing and some kid
disrespected me the other night I don't
know what your [ __ ] name is don't do
it again that backward the Comedy Store
I am as high as [ __ ] yeah everything's
kicking in at once right the blue pills
the reefer I don't drink when I'm done
okay you just will be left alone huh my
funnest thing in life right now the only
real entertainment I have just when you
have a spot yeah at whatever time but
you make yourself a promise that you're
gonna go 45 minutes early mm-hmm
go on the back let's zip a quick number
and drink some water and sit and Mitzi's
chairs mm-hmm and just watch the three
guys before you yeah you owe it to
yourself
they were on a lineup for a reason and
it's so weird because I could feel my
body sinking and sinking and sinking and
I get sucked in by their material Oh
and I learned something yeah and it may
be something you could call back when
you go up I love it that's awesome
that's something about that but I can't
go to an open mic and sit in the back
with our people torture me but that last
row at the Comedy Store
mm-hmm is for me I got put well I twist
my leg all the way around like a [ __ ]
sumo wrestler yeah you're so flexible
yeah I want to watch run light I want to
see you yeah I want to watch bill burr I
want to see Chris D'Elia the same way
you do yeah
what's up why you bother me and when
they talk to me they don't know they're
breaking like ten layers of I'm that
deep yeah
like to go that deep without doing
heroin is impossible like I'm focusing
I'm zero and there's an unfortunate
Eames time watching their hands I'm
watching her body language that's how
you become a [ __ ] cop
yeah by watching a really good comic and
just studying them are they calling it
in hmm oh my god like a fortune she used
her hand to sell that joke yeah so
that's interesting one night I was
sitting back there hi his [ __ ] watch him
go BRR laughing like everybody else
right
looking at the lineups when I go down
they have a look at the lineups like I
don't know where I'm going who's up next
how these four yeah I don't want to look
at the lineup just all the time it's
like going to the doctor's office to get
your tooth pulp mm-hmm you want to know
I don't want to know okay I don't want
to know when I'm at the night they call
me and they go 10:30 I don't want to
make a sign
sometimes they put the roster up and
I'll retweet it mm-hmm and that's how
I'll see you is on the lineup right I
really for the most part yeah don't pee
I don't wanna know that's the beginning
of the end right what you gotta follow
crystal you die you're dead how you
gonna be thinking about it yeah you know
when I see like Nancy whatever and I
know it's [ __ ] whatever her name is
I'm not I'm saying it's right
I got a follow her and it's fine yeah
but I'm watching bill he's ripping apart
a room he goes coming to the stage
fortune favors that now you know six
people seven people walked out because
it's bill
right and me being a student of the game
let's see what fortunes what hands
watching that I'm right out there
watching you one up there like Bill's
got a big dick take a look at my nutsack
Road bills energy oh man my nuts says oh
my god you just rode the energy and I
sat in the back of I'm like this is
[ __ ] phenomenal cuz I'm not saying
anything bad about women but six out of
ten women would have phones in that
situation especially after this set that
he had in that tiny original room at
9:45 that's a tough tough tough room
yeah I'm 45 you know so I always fell in
love with you I was like what where'd
you start well thank you for that though
that means that means a lot
yeah where'd you start I started at the
Comedy Store no yeah well I started in
sketch and improv so I was a Groundlings
person and you don't back then
especially you did not see sketching
improv people do stand-up they were very
separate very separate and people the
growlings were not alone we need the
groundlings for I did the growlings for
about seven years
do you regret it now I'm proud that I
did it because that's where I learned
how to be a good actor it was so
character based and it was creating a
lot of characters from nothing and it
really
sharpen my writing skills I direct I was
in the Sunday company for a year and a
half and you have to put on a new sketch
show once a week every weekend it's a
new show so you're writing like 5 to 7
new sketches a week for a year and a
half is a lot
it was great training but I I started
stand-up the beginning of 2007 what made
you want to start I just I knew there
was every time I saw some performance
stand up there was something inside of
me it was like I got it I gotta do this
this looks like the greatest thing ever
but if I was like scared I was like how
how do you be a stand-up what would I
talk about and I took a class
it took a stand-up class I would improv
you have six people yeah these ideas so
now you're alone no I'm alone what's
that show alone afraid
yeah it's you in a microphone you're
coming from bouncing ideas well you've
all they for but Leah bring us back yeah
you know I I just I did this class you
were uh Adam Barnhart absolutely yeah he
I took his class and then he you know I
he did a show every Sunday night yeah
great guy yeah since I got here for sure
and after his class he was like why
don't you do the music for the show and
I'll give you ten minutes every Sunday
night and you as a brand other brand new
comment I got ten minutes at the in the
belly room every Sunday night for a year
and it made me stronger it made me grow
a lot faster because stage time is the
hardest thing to get did you get spots
during the week or so anywhere else were
you going I was going on I was doing a
lot of gay shows I was going to they
were at the time they're all these like
alternative shows and and gay rooms were
like gay comics from performing so I was
getting up in other places but the store
was so you know coveted it was so hard
it was gritty cuz now the store is like
popping again everybody's going there
the shows are full when I started it was
empty
yeah that's when I left
yeah like a toe
was kind of weird Brogan's got thrown
right yeah right around that time that
was it I just heard reports that it was
kind of weird yeah it was hard there
just no one was going to the shows and
and so I was going up and then I did a
show like a random show in LA and Bret
Ernst was there and he was like you're
really you're really funny if you
showcase from it see and I'm like no I'm
just you know two years in he's like you
got you gotta Tommy's got to see you and
so you know Bret like made it happen he
like tell Tommy you guys see her you got
to see her and finally Tommy let me go
up and that helped me get to the other
rooms and then that eventually led to me
showcasing for Mitzi I just showcased
the on the video cuz that I think Justin
Martin Dilla just gotten passed she
randomly saw him perform in the main
room and then she didn't watch anybody
in person after that right she got sick
yeah but I so they would do it over
video so she watched me over a video oh
she wouldn't love you right well yes she
saw she saw um Tommy always said she
said interest interesting interesting
yeah give her a shout yeah if she wants
to be a doorman I should have been a
doorman female doorman they do yeah
Carmen Morales and Emily were Vera no
three and then Jessica long yep yeah
yeah so they uh they she passed me up so
I went from I didn't she didn't make me
a paid regular right away for a year I
was a regular in the Friday night belly
room store so I had to work my way up
for a year which yeah of course great
yeah I need it I needed that and then
after a year they were like alright you
ready
and I went started in the or and I was
like oh my god I mean it was the biggest
honor
I got made of paid regular in 2010 and
it was before I was on TV it made me go
Chelsea yet no Chelsea so it made me
feel like a real comic you know because
sometimes
people get past their good comics but
it's more like oh what TV show are they
on right and not everyone just that does
happen and I just felt like I got it
because I proved I was a stand-up well
she loved characters mm-hmm okay so my
god I got past a month after I got here
oh really
Doug Stanhope got me a show yeah whole
thing I hope people would come to me
over the years ago huh yeah oh [ __ ] I
never really thought about really until
I got here I went down there yeah for
the open mic and no I guess she said
yeah yeah Stanhope Scott day yeah they
both put it together and boom and then
but she loved characters sometimes she
wouldn't go like this guy isn't that
funny
yeah but she saw character there and she
want them to develop that character
right and soon enough that person
wouldn't want to take it there because
it was all right Agnes mm-hmm they
wouldn't get spots Oh interesting yeah
he wanted you to be a certain thing and
she pushed you into it yeah you know
that that was and the store push it
pushed you in the right direction I
could tell by watching you on stage yeah
that you were kind of like I haven't
been here [ __ ] I was i stayed out of
the store for it seven years yeah I
don't know I don't realize you'd stay
away that long I stayed away though yeah
and then it was doughy uh that was the
birth of deliever you know he was coming
up in Del Rey you know I would hear from
Aria I was tight with our yeah don't get
all those guys mm-hmm so I would hear
what was going on in the store but ya
know she would have loved you whom they
want I mean isn't it cool though like
your story my story like how these other
comics who have gotten to a certain
level they reach back down and like I
want to help you out now like with Doug
with you Brett with me like I don't know
I feel like you hear a lot of stories
out of LA Hollywood where people were
like so cutthroat but with stand up
there like you she needs to see you you
gotta get in front of this you know I
mean like it's cool to see people
looking out for each other there and
that way not that everyone does that but
know this people look out for themselves
one you know what makes you a better
comic is not being judgmental or
something like Jesus Christ I wish
nobody sees fortune oh he knows there
might go my spots right if you think
that way you're a [ __ ] idiot yeah
yeah it's like what we have is like
going to the track my mother died of a
broken heart if you asked not she died
of a heart attack
hmm but it was basically a broken heart
yeah Chinese call a broken heart
so his dance don't feel Ralphie Oh died
of a broken heart
yes 900 pounds joy you don't know what
you're talking about he loses when you
lose that will dur ya to live my mother
came from a school that if she went out
and got ten thousand mandatorily she was
supposed to give away six really for
good luck to come back to you mm-hmm
the problem is not everybody plays
according to those rules right yeah she
would go we hit the mother for ten gave
me final hours yeah and then if so I
saying something to leave you would
break her heart
mm-hmm so with Tommy you have to be the
same way mm-hmm
you have to look out for the people
around you you know you have to throw
them bones or it's to serve yeah there's
a lot of people who come at you
expecting something right you and I both
look at a comic because you've been
doing it now know when somebody's faking
default yeah okay I know the rise of
that I don't have to hear your material
I don't have to hear you join just going
they're going to rule for five minutes
and I know exactly where you are in your
career yeah because I've been there and
I've seen people that you know I still
remember going to towns as a feature
yeah have people go you're headlining
for the future this guy's gonna be a
badass [ __ ] and you know and I
saw people come and go yeah and the
people who stayed were the people who
kept it consistently knew who the [ __ ]
they were and stayed within their bounds
and just kept plugging along
little by little normally you know one
week you're a feature in Michigan and
actually
MC in Boston the following week a
co-headlining in Maine
you know the following week you're out
there on the road you're grinding it
you're experiencing different why I was
doing with Patriots so good because Tom
Brady knows how to read of defense he
knows how to make audibles when you go
on the road you know me going into the
Bible Belt in North Carolina
I remember going into the Bible Belt at
99 year mark yeah obviously tell you I
went 5 0 4 5 movie it's tough I bombed
in Carolina I bombed that [ __ ] the
University of Miami no I bombed the
Clark Tennessee the Bible Belt would
take a ride with me for eight minutes
and then it comes back to them let their
Christian deep down inside and they look
at them telling me we can't laugh at
this I saw them do it to stand up in
Nashville yeah in 98 mm-hmm
and I swore to got the bombing I took
the Nashville it look like Vietnam
missiles were coming from everywhere Oh
I swore never to go back to that have
you never gone back oh yeah sure is a
car right but also they would sure is
atomic yeah it's good to go to the south
to the Bible Belt
oh [ __ ] and eat yeah 22 nights oh but I
shouldn't New Jersey you know I haven't
been to be sure they in a while I'm
gonna do I just in New York and it was
awesome but this is I'm talking about
back when I was first story yes I big
[ __ ] yeah Jersey but you didn't go back
to New Jersey now I haven't I was last
here sometime I was here a year ago you
didn't like me what I see what the [ __ ]
and you take them for the ride places I
go to now that I promised I would never
step in that state again it was when you
bomb in this state yeah and you runs a
bus on the way out yeah
you feel like the the fugitive mother
chased me down and shoot me like you're
on the bus fidgeting when you just did
seven shows at a club is a feature and
you died five out of the seven shows mm
when you got even when the owners paying
you you feel like [ __ ] oh there's the
worst feeling but you don't know that
you're gonna get that lady
you ran just a lesson you got yeah don't
blame it on the audience
you didn't come at that audience
prepared right you didn't watch the
emcee you didn't watch the headline of
the first night you got to watch those
guys and see how they met how many times
you go onstage eat a bag of dicks guy
goes up and every day the guy goes up
behind you and he I remember there was a
comic years ago that closed with a wig
and stockings and held on oh and he was
gonna standing ovations okay and I would
leave they're about ready his [ __ ]
shoot myself what am I doing wrong I
would loved in either bag of dick
yeah I remember working with him like
New Year's when you die in LA I worked
in Channel and I died like yeah there
was a two-year mark there where I was
just dying on the road but I know that
when I was a regular at the store
already was already regular at the store
but I hadn't hit that 10-year mark
mm-hmm and I said you know what I'm
gonna go be even though I'm a regular at
the store I'm gonna go back out to war
again cuz I'm not prepared yeah and all
those tales of Myrtle Beach mm-hmm
how was that Myrtle Beach I liked the
owners yeah it was booked out of know
Waukee at the time uh yeah she was
really hot and he was uh they were a
couple then ran the club in Milwaukee
and how you made money down there was
the only page for 400 to feature okay
from Tuesday this Saturday but during
the day you took condo toys oh really
time chair oh yeah if you sat through
the whole week to give you $150 oh yeah
so you go to for those during the week
yeah it makes 600 or whatever it was 75
15
what the [ __ ] it was but I did that and
I like no that was cool because that was
a vacation place yeah the beach song was
different people but that whole creative
run at the time creative as I just
burned carrot top mm-hmm
so they had a great run of rooms yeah
and I don't forget my manager calling me
at the time he have left creative
entertainment then come on manage and he
goes you got nine like bad reports Oh
like out of the 16 rooms uh-huh my the
room said don't ever want it oh no jeez
and you learn from that
yeah take your feelings hurt Oh what
Virginia was the worst leg on top never
performing West Virginia on top of a
ping-pong table and you had to sign a
contract that you couldn't say the word
[ __ ] laughs you said the word [ __ ] they
would call the police and find you $50
Wow well I just went up damn bombed cuz
I need that 50 that was where I drove
the guy he drove me to get coconut mess
yeah like how much of it
what's a percentage of you bombing or
was it you just not being right for the
room was it a mix of both it was ready
for the room not being ready listen it's
not the punch that you throw em you know
fortune that punch I thought I was gonna
punch you in the head no matter what
yeah it's the next punch and how you're
gonna react you blocked that left and
then you get me in the stomach come up
on an uppercut and I'm bleeding now
you're bleeding now we gotta fight yeah
and that's what you're not prepared for
that you just let me come up and punch
you twice and you gave up right you have
to learn how to get yourself out of that
hole
there's judging you within the first
seven seconds mm-hmm they're in [ __ ]
hell's Vil hell's Carolina and you know
the first Jew they've seen them 11 years
yeah
you're Jewish skin is softer I got good
Desert Sun over there
Juiz Jew is Laham day though you know
then now then you have to learn how to
make yourself one of them yeah and look
at you from that perspective and that's
what Texas came into it what happened in
Texas Texas they take the ride with you
oh yeah I love Texas it doesn't take the
ride with you I love once you get in
there seven minutes you got it you know
Houston you can't say Bush yeah think
about the bush is in Austin you could
jump up and down the flag you say
something about the bushes how they
don't issue bow and arrows then in the
airport oh yeah don't you mention
nothing about barber boys talk about you
just even the deejay don't push push
push in the bush that song is bad then
[ __ ] these don't say [ __ ] bush but
anything else that take the ride with
you saw as a feature act I developed
really well in Texas because they let
you tell ya
and in Texas to hand out holes during a
week no no we can get did froggy bottoms
a be room did the last stop you had the
last spot the last stop you know you had
[ __ ] the Dallas improv you had the one
with Ralphie may fell through the stage
Oh stage with fritters whatever what the
Oldham problem you felt the stay he kept
it secret for years that's why I found
out that I would breaking ball from time
to time before Spellbinders yeah because
I remember call talked to the lady who
booked it and he goes don't mention my
name
oh yes she told me you felt through the
stage no I didn't the stage was faulty
therefore falter no stage even Tennessee
like when I went back to visit my
in-laws I took a ride to Paducah and
then they were great yeah I went it was
a coffee shop you been everywhere though
you have to I know as a comedian like
listen I'm not a big I'm not gonna lie I
barely keep it together on LA to New
York mm-hmm la the one the next 12 [ __ ]
it now I'm about to do I'm doing these
guys that do this Malaysian runs a [ __ ]
like that I like that but I'm gonna sit
on the plane smelling hummus feet that
[ __ ] one of those people they take
their shoes off and click that toes and
you got ass it's different
everybody today there's no class in the
airline industry anymore they put a big
a Twitter picture up of a dude oh yeah
that's right somebody somebody posted up
yeah there is no class anymore what do
you do if the guy next to you started
doing that I would [ __ ] take the
plane down I would I would take my sleep
apnea machine with it it's so crazy
crazy crazy as it is like I already all
right people
all right let's get out of the way you
guys take care yourself so I pack a pack
in my sleep apnea machine uh-huh I got a
pack of [ __ ] disinfectant wipes and
yeah no germ wipes I wipe this down yeah
that's a tray they say the tray has more
germs than [ __ ] if you take a chance
demand coming in a thousand times put in
the crack cause ass leave it there for a
year and pull it out that [ __ ] tray
has more germs than that dead [ __ ]
condom yeah cuz people like change their
baby's diapers on you get on a [ __ ]
plane huh the first thing you do is you
wipe that down I got a straw by the
[ __ ] window I'm I don't give a [ __ ] I
didn't know you were a manager before
yeah but we're comedians yes a what
happens if you catch the flu for 10 days
sir I got a reschedule now and then you
go out too early you're gonna get sicker
your long yeah your coffee everywhere
the mask on a plane yeah unless I got
scotch tape to put out my eyes like a
Japanese who else gets away with that oh
why do with a mask I gotta go smack you
in the [ __ ] face like that we've got
to the Japanese they do that I've never
had a mask no you can't wear a mask on
but you need to eat something to protect
yourself and you know you don't know
wolf I wash my hands before I take a
piss out of respect for my wife I don't
want to suffer yeah yeah yeah and even
now I'm over 50 I want nobody sucking my
dick Tom what's disgusting you don't
want any no job no no I wouldn't put
that out no but that's psychological
abuse all right
I'm 55 I mean it's nice that's really
nice it smells like sauce I call folks
home you know family oh man boss well
nobody's you're really nice cuz most
guys are like I don't give a [ __ ] you
know I've always been a three showered
day type of guy Matt's always tip-top
Magoo what but watch this tap my gu let
me pay you sup even with the coin stop
you can't stop the 5850 I just get those
dusty born starts right away when I come
out of the shower oh my I put my [ __ ]
panties and you dip them in cornstarch
no I take corn starch powder yeah
because you can buy powder at the
supermarket we're trying to learn how to
take care of my balls well ladies kit
the problem is when we can't put that
see when I was growing up and you ate
somebody's [ __ ] yeah you could smell
the talcum powder baby powder
oh that everyone used to use baby powder
because it would marinate the [ __ ] it's
like putting saran wrap on a piece
marinated nice that keeps the inside
nice and well k yeah but that women
started losing their kidneys hard balls
everything I'm watching you use talcum
powder in the 80s are you [ __ ] koalas
now you obviously
I don't know what an ovulating I don't
know you were like they all had great
smelling [ __ ] but they died of cancer
don't die the [ __ ] oh very cool [ __ ]
she's not supposed to put talcum powder
but I've never said nothing about the
dick and I grew up my time compiling so
far you're good to go
yeah I gotta tell you this after like
after 30 my dick was fine good call
about 24 I [ __ ] this weight at 24 it
started changing I had some wing to it
okay no fish I used to bang this chick
without a condom shoes a filthy animal I
still talk to it what a shame my dick
change smells for like a year after you
had sex oh there yeah wait we're back
the world it wouldn't go away have you
showered yeah if I shall with it okay it
went away on the opposite I don't like
marinated deep on the inside if I
scratch my helmet at night it was to the
fishy did it make you nervous to have
sex with women after that like you were
you afraid that that was gonna happen
again or you always let's get some other
way yeah Joey I can't wait what page
1516 a buddy of mine came from like a
man he goes listen I got something hmm
would you come with me to the clinic mmm
but I went in from the clinic and I sat
across I don't know if he was gay I'm
not gonna say anything
yeah he had something on his mouth the
whole time oh and besides my Catholic
upbringing I always had that that image
so until the age of 18 I can't lie to
you I wasn't going for [ __ ] right
like there's something wrong with that
[ __ ] guy's mouth yeah I can't think
of the bothers mouth that is I got old
and I started doing drugs you studied
ass and [ __ ] what's reading anything
yeah yeah what's you and even if this is
got a little dirt to it like sometimes
they took a [ __ ] it too but you read
their ass at 9:00 this is that little
Wang to it day I'm saying but you don't
give a [ __ ] what are you gonna embarrass
them and tell them to go use the bidet
no you're
we or anyone in the cave like the little
Thai kids there's no coming back
[Laughter]
listen do you talk about that's what we
share in common even though I'm never
like the woman's [ __ ] no you're the
boss of the relationship at the strap-on
on a hill in the face and a [ __ ] and my
paper I would assume that if you're oh
yeah so staring at you just fiance I
would marry you she doesn't like that
stuff a lot of women don't you not a lot
once you eat the [ __ ] you gotta eat the
[ __ ] yeah but no no you can't go from
the [ __ ] to the [ __ ] right say why
won't you eat the ass on the ass keep
fingering them but you're talking about
before you get some how to respect
you'll get some double Listerine and you
wipe your face with a Thursday I'm
learning so much today it's so weird I
really am would you like when you're 20
are you doing comedy right like now the
trip will run yeah there's so many women
that you'll bump into and because you're
on stage and they're from this small
town afterwards you're like a [ __ ]
celebrity you could tell them whatever
you want that you know James Franciscus
you know Steve McQueen
they're like enamored with you no matter
what you look right you don't know how
many [ __ ] you get on the road and at
the end they want to kiss you unless
they you know you want to get it on or
whatever but that's how you get the flu
questions season vixen got the flu only
pushing it the flu what I
and don't you read somebody's [ __ ] in
the next day you throw feels weird maybe
I never put two and two together I don't
know times like weird strange [ __ ] yeah
what what you wouldn't kiss them would
you eat lick your [ __ ] yeah I would
lick their ass yes always staring you in
the face you just can't leave with this
I can little puppy you see a little
puppy you always go back when you pet
him a little bit that's just like an
[ __ ] you swung on the other side for
oh I came out at 25 I never had sex with
a man I think I might have had sex I
might have had sex with a guy back in
the day but nobody wanted to but I think
part of it is that when you're gay even
if you don't like I did it wasn't like I
was in the closet I just didn't know
that I was gay I didn't realize that
about myself and I think that that when
you're gay you put out some sort of I
don't know if it's pheromone whatever
another person picks up on it so
whatever I was putting out not realizing
it was not received by men men always
like came up to me like a buddy
high-five and immediately there was
always a very buddy type of relationship
so I never really dated I didn't how I
went on a few dates with guys but I
never had like a serious boyfriend or
anything like that because I was just
friends with with males but I I had had
I been had I had someone in my life or
dated someone like that I might have had
sex but just didn't I was the first time
you looked at a woman of ripped off
pocket shirt off I was like one at that
age I came out 25 what are you five
yeah so I was a bit of a late bloomer if
I started earlier I'd probably be I
probably had liked ass because I was a
late bloomer it was too far down on the
totem pole you know
he's won the last two podcast saying I
should look ass I don't I have no
interest you don't want to do it what is
the who does it pleasure the most the
person getting the ass looking or the
person doing it let me ask you a
question you're driving home after a
long day your mother died of leukemia
that's quite a one thing that's the
worst that's somebody with your [ __ ]
at some point you're like my dog got hit
by a car but guess what
yeah an 82 a girl laughs my ass like it
was [ __ ] honey and she had no [ __ ]
spoons there yeah you know I mean no I
don't know I don't know I didn't like it
you weren't into it I like having sex
with a woman and eating her ass as part
of the Pope thing like late night you
know like a different part of it saying
you have seven [ __ ] but you go to a
French restaurant they give you three
dishes the same thing you suck the titty
you gotta suck the monkey and then you
gotta get the dessert in the air so you
got to get the it's a fortune cookie
oh man Joey I'm learning a lot too yeah
every day it's Monday morning you can't
drop [ __ ] knowledge oh I feel like
this this particular episode will
inspire more people to go out there and
try it oh they should try something yeah
there's gotta work you gotta change
things up every now so what do you think
about your future me you know you had a
TV deal for a while with my girl there I
yeah I mean you don't stop I don't stop
I do a lot that's why you know we were
saying it I haven't been around the
comedy scene here in LA lately I have a
weird trajectory with my stand-up I told
you you know I started a comedy store
and then by a certain 2007 I got Chelsea
Lately at 2011 I went from a fairly new
comic to that show which was very
popular at the time I became I went from
new comic to headliner like that so I
had to like learn how to become I didn't
get the opportunity to go on the road
with people as a features of opener I
would have loved the experience of
watching other comics I would watch them
coming up
story you know but I didn't I didn't get
to learn from anybody on the road I was
just like bigger and it out the
experience like when you first got
thrown out there how many is how you
been onstage when you first got thrown
out there the headline I started I
started standing up the beginning 2007 I
was headlining by summer of 2010 cuz I
did Last Comic Standing and then Chelsea
Lately back to back and so I was
terrified I'd gone from just trying to
figure out my 15 minute spot at the
store to like oh now I got a perform
minimum 45 minutes I but that's where my
growling straining came into play I
started doing a lot of audience I
started talking to the audience a lot
sergeant a lot of crowd work until I
could get my material build-up but so
basically like since then I've just been
hustling
I went from Chelsea Lately to acting
acting it's kind of come to the
forefront for me bill bill Cooper always
gets mad at me he's like quit this
acting crap you're a stand-up get up
there and I'm so I've been focusing more
stand-up lately not that I'm pushing
acting aside but I don't know I'm just
doing everything I can to just work you
know I did the Mindy project for three
seasons and then I did this NBC show
last year but this last year I've been
not only getting back into stand-up a
lot I've always toward I never stopped
touring but I've been trying to work on
my new hour I want to try to sell a
special I've done two half hours but
never a full hour special for somewhere
I don't know but I I just like until I
don't know I found oh the one 1/2 hours
Comedy Central and one was for Netflix
they did like this series of half-hour
but I feel like until you do you're our
special you know you know that's like a
coveted thing for stand-ups and I really
want to make that special and so I'm
working on that and then I've been
developing a lot of stuff I sold two
movies that I wrote with two of my
writing partners to Amblin that Steven
Steven Spielberg's company so we're
seeing that through that process how
does that process oh right in movies
it's really hard I had sold two TV
pilots before that and they're hard but
nothing near running a movie because it
we've been on this we've been working on
this one movie with last two years and
wrote and that's just with amylin being
attached we were working on a year
before that and it's always evolving
always changing and you have to keep up
with 130 pages like with a pilot it's
like 35 pages you can keep track with 35
pages fairly easy you're like oh I know
I happen on page 4 and page 20 they're
not that far apart where's a hunting 35
to 150 pages yo my god I don't know what
happened in that scene on page 50 I have
no idea and it changes so much that
you're like constantly losing track of
your story but you know it's cool to try
I mean I hope I get the chance to get up
to making I'd be in I would be in the
movies if they got made now let me ask
you this when you went to pitch them
mm-hmm you went to pitch a thought or
you walked in there with the script
prepared the first one people at home
the first one I sold
we sold as a script well I had done a
tiny part in this movie called an office
Christmas party I played this over
driver and Steven Spielberg's company
produced it and they were like or they
were the studio and they were like what
we want to work with you
what do you got and I was like well we
we've been working on the script and
they bought it and so that was really
cool but then you go through a bunch of
rewrite processes with that and then the
second movie we sold to them
in October we sold as a pitch we went in
there and told them the idea I mean you
think it out really in detail we we
worked on an outline for like six months
and then you go pitch that and they
bought that and then we just turned in
the first draft I have no idea how many
stars have to be aligned oh so a pilot a
TV show I saw so many people have three
drinks in them and gone my father gets
picked up I'm gonna make you the
bartender uh-huh pilot gets picked up
I'm gonna make you this
probably gets picked up and it never
happened it never happens
I still remember people who did deals
with Dave Letterman yeah they would be
bragging and those are the worst once
again all right because CBS don't want
to deal with they don't want to deal
with David Letterman they know a red
tape they want people who don't know
what they doing so he could smack them
around take notes and tell them you'll
never work again but if you get the
Conan O'Brien Cohen is gonna go shut the
[ __ ] out right so they never so I saw
all those comics and when you look
process
yeah I saw comics that you know shot the
pilot and one call of me see at will the
highest-rated pilots of Walter really
that's a well-known fact 100% across the
board
yeah a Barney Miller show when his
heyday right 96 97 mm-hmm the last
minute I know another girl who sold a
show and they shot 11 episodes at NBC
and in there any today oh that would be
painful you know so I never really know
where you stand all you could do is
thank God I'm here too yeah thank god
this cheque is clearing today they got
craft service they got bagels they got
LOX
yeah they got onions I'm good for today
people really don't understand right the
process and then the notes oh yeah and
you're taking notes not for more comic
you take a note from a college student
yeah somebody who's know somebody who
was a comedy yeah no no you know what
the Syracuse I'm not putting down
anybody from Syracuse I'm just saying
that they're the managers and agents and
a lot of people you deal with yeah and
you went to school for four years
intern we've been at growlings for seven
years on standby just a comedy store for
five then on the road you got to listen
to what the [ __ ] was saying yeah you
know what would Chappelle did that
Comedy Central I knew that what that was
about it was about some guy coming and
telling me who's got the number-one show
what time it is do yourself a favor get
the [ __ ] out of this room yeah
go get your [ __ ] degree from USC
[ __ ] acting school though short to
somebody will matter still over here in
the trenches right that's why we
respected
in the beginning mm-hmm Roseanne told
him that work go [ __ ] themselves in the
early oh yeah a goal was to beat Cosby
right well they beat Cosby they tried to
go under accept responsibility she's
like no it was me who hadn't picked the
staff of writers yeah exactly what was
gonna work your guys idea was not gonna
work
right you know when you look at the
rocky story they wanted Burt Reynolds
for the part of Rocky mm-hmm they wanted
Ryan O'Neal a part of Rocky you know
it's like they come to you tomorrow and
they go we love this but for this role
we think yeah this guy didn't like
hundred-percent I can ask them [ __ ]
crazy yeah I don't want that guy my
[ __ ] movie and that's the crazy part
and I learned that I sold a pilot in
2015 and it was for ABC and Tina Fey was
the producer and writer yeah any pots
play my mom John Carroll Lynch was my
dad and we shot it and it tested really
really high you you have all the stars
you think are aligned do you think one
of the co-creator was a 30 rock writer
with me and and then all of a sudden you
just get that phone call that's like ah
we loved it but it's not happening and
you know it's a huge I think I learned
more from that note than anything in
this video I mean it felt like [ __ ] you
know cuz it was my story was based on my
life and it almost felt more personal
like you're being told no because it's
based on your life that was one of the
hardest nodes I've ever gotten I felt
like [ __ ] and and I hate this but it
made me put my computer away for like a
year I did not develop I did not write
anything for like a year and it and then
after I finally like came out of that
was like [ __ ] that
like I'm gonna I'm gonna keep making
stuff I'm gonna make this happen and
I've been writing for the last two and a
half years non-stop how disciplined are
you I'm not as disciplined as I want to
be when it comes to writing stand-up I
really need to be better about making
myself right
the problem is I get so busy writing
these other things that stand-up
sometimes goes to the wayside
but when it comes to movies and TV stuff
I'm very disciplined I have two writing
partners and we weed every day we get on
the phone at 10:00 a.m. and don't stop
until 4:00 and we do it Monday through
Friday really mm-hmm
how'd you get off tonight uh well we
just started a new idea and I just and
we've been working on it all week and I
just said can we just pick this back up
when I cause I'm in I'm in London this
whole week and from the fourth through
the 9th where you performed in the Soho
Theatre at 1:00 you sold out all those
they're not sold out I mean they've been
doing well I don't think they're sold
out but it's been a good a good turnout
so far so well I'll see you go all the
way in there just London doing six shows
there and then I want to go to Paris for
fun for a few days you're bringing the
fiance oh yeah maybe we'll get into that
a Slifkin oh yeah she'll never she'll
never do KTLA got o house listen Stern
you believe that she gets this [ __ ] but
that's when you're like you know that's
not gay that's that you don't think
that's gay he was with a dude wasn't
yeah I don't think that's gay I like
wanting to banner together and they love
each other
[ __ ] disappointed it's just like no I
can see a woman putting the [ __ ]
strap-on on like having fun with their
wives right you know that's what it
called for I don't know where this
[ __ ] comes in that category what I
see what I see gay guys marching
yeah they look really cute that's good
dance ain't enough now beautiful it's
love yes
nowhere in that is there a fist in some
ways and now we know on your fingernails
can't be satisfied with a regular dick
alright switch up go up great oh nice
big black nigerian dick like Jesse's
Smollett get one of those [ __ ] all
those things if there's an earthquake
you can hang on today yeah you look like
one of those [ __ ] in Katrina on
it but a [ __ ] fist yeah have you
would you want this anybody want this
that's a [ __ ] no no maybe the guy had
small wrist I was looking at Mike
Tyson's hand down but what are the other
fist [ __ ] that dude that dude will be
deadness that should destroy you right
here this yeah and he was getting fisted
in the butt yeah how do they know that
yeah how do they know that they got once
they do you autopsy and they can fit a
[ __ ] [ __ ] the toy in your ass while
I'm doing the autopsy and they flip you
over and I go hold on and he's sitting
there with a guilty look on him yes
and a dirty fingernail it's dirty
fingernails I just try to wipe this
[ __ ] handle yeah I do wear glove I
mean if I put my hands up somebody's ass
right now but if you're into that kind
of stuff you're not worrying I'm not
into that bum you say no not you just a
person yeah they really disturbed me
like that's that and Jesse Smollett last
week really [ __ ] of me yeah because on
one hand you know I see how hard
everybody works be [ __ ] accepted
right you know I love goofing on people
I love having a good time but I also see
them people just trying to be accepted
we have a dear friend who's a gay
comedian I love them to death
mm-hmm you know my little buddy he and I
love them to death but that doesn't mean
them to me but even gay people walk in
your wagon gay guys on the bar and often
this this guy was fist [ __ ] they even
they would go like Hollywood gay guys
yeah it's like it's a lot my friend was
at a party one day oh and he's uh he was
friends with the gay couple and they had
like on the gay couples over there yeah
and somebody mentioned your comic friend
of his
one guy goes let me tell you something I
went to the comedy store and saw that
guy he said Queen he said what the chick
that got killed in the car wreck oh damn
princess died yes I went down there that
guy called princess but I had her [ __ ]
and he goes the whole room the gay guys
with that's gay I love that stuff yeah
but no worry the game man you want do
you hear about this [ __ ] with two
meth rocks up you're the kid very
offended Lee yes I mean [ __ ] I'm
offended that you will let's I did coke
for 27 years you never put up your
butthole never not even thought about it
not even one finger not even one night
what I sit there and go wait a sec I
need to be a little bit higher because I
heard my first movie yeah I had an agent
for a while and he was old school
Sinatra age but he was all school flame
he was a theatre hmm and he was very
dear he was a great agent to me yeah he
didn't get me out enough but he got me
out yeah like he didn't get you out ten
times a year he got you out six yeah you
weren't for the heavy [ __ ] do oh
that's cool one day I took him out to
lunch and he was just telling me about
the 70s gay scene really Hollywood how
you'd go on I bought by the Gold's Gym
on how far is it
it's a tomorrow yeah yeah it's a
different Street there's a new old
here's the our Tower
oh yeah knows that that's where all the
underground game places work oh really
that would be a red light would be out
and those red lights that means you went
downstairs and they would put ecstasy
and burn it down with viagra and pull it
in turkey basters hmm and he would shoot
up your ass uh-huh and when he was it's
like me going to you let me tell you
something yeah I went to a fabulous
party
tonight because I had never forget his
office was across the street Laurel
Canyon and Sun and Ventura aha if you go
north there's a Starbucks on the corner
yeah
if you cross that Street and take ten
steps he was upstairs okay and I would
sit up say you know he's real close to
me I would come up to do other things
and I'd stop and there's Nathan and I
can't even say his name I would go up
there and say what's going on you know
oh my god I gotta call you for three
days what happened oh my god yeah that
turkey baster is the viagra and ecstasy
and you put the truth oh I just go off
the [ __ ] rails a gal I've mugged some
people uh-huh I've done some crazy
things I've never thought of putting a
turkey baster up your ass who would you
trust in charge of the doses no I mean I
would get the dosage ready yeah yeah but
if you're gay I think you don't care
who's doing it you're just like put it
up there what is cool I like that you're
you've always been so accepting of gay
people because sometimes you know you're
just you seem like the type who's kind
of like hey you do your thing I'll do my
thing
oh my mother had a bar and we were
involved in Santeria
my mom had a lot of gay friends growing
up hmm and when I was about seven there
was one I used to always go to beef with
I would always go to war with him
because he would say things to me one of
these days I'm gonna [ __ ] you oh yeah
yeah my mother really please yeah he
would say crazy [ __ ]
one day I said to him say that again I
hope you [ __ ] die [ __ ] two days
later he died no my mom sat me down
because that's why you don't say that
should be yeah we had a lot of gay
friends but there was one that really at
that age I didn't understand right no
one well he gone mad mm-hmm his name was
Medina Mariko that's what they call him
as part of his nickname Street uh-huh
and Martina Mariko was a seamstress for
a big-time player
cats mm-hmm no it wasn't cats cuz I was
12 13 11 and I was just getting into
music yeah
was this in Jersey this isn't North
Jersey yeah and before he went into the
city at night he would stop at my
mother's bar and have a drink yeah some
nights you would have a broken wrist
some nights you would have a black eye
really some nights he would have a thick
lip but I go what happened uh-huh
and he'd go to CBGB's and he'd say the
[ __ ] guys down to call and they'd
jump us everyday oh really
this is 1970 okay guys were still
getting jumped in yeah in New York was
hard had their own area but it was
hardcore yeah I wish I didn't know he
was putting his dick up people's asses
of people but I was too young to fathom
right what enamored me to him was that
he always spoke to me he found time to
talk to me
mm-hmm and he would always tell me the
band he saw last night yeah he would see
the clash and you know the [ __ ] guy
who did heroin and he would talk about
all those bands to me and I would hear
about CBGB but I was too young and then
something happened one day that changed
my whole view in the corner of the bar
there were these two bookmakers that
were brothers mm-hmm
and they would sit there from 10:00 to
4:00 and drink no one day Martin came in
and there was a shuffleboard yeah behind
so Martin was here and those two guys
were at least picture is you see Lee's
picture mm-hmm and the one guy goes hey
look who it is mighty damn muddy cold
mm-hmm and mud but like five hours on
the bar and he [ __ ] pulled the gun
out of his jack any point that the two
guys named yeah until you suck my dick
oh I suck your dick don't ever
disrespect me and call me my damn money
phone and my mother started yelling cuz
one of the guys had a gun yeah and the
guys like what the [ __ ] is your problem
he goes well I told you don't you ever
disrespect me again yeah and my mother
kept yelling my teens put the gun down
copito is right behind you he would have
pulled out his gun there would have been
a shootout right right yeah so
he looked at eating look at my mother he
told my mother uh-huh that he needs to
see this
yeah even though I'm a [ __ ] you gotta
respect me like a man right
okay don't call me that huh he put the
[ __ ] gun away and my mom started tell
him you're not allowed in here no more
get the [ __ ] out my peen how can you do
something like that my team won we got a
bus and I'm not oh and the other guy
started saying next time we see em we're
gonna put a bullet in him and all this
[ __ ] and two days later I was home at my
house and he knocked on the door I
didn't know his him yeah I know what's
up man he goes listen I thought about
what happened mmm-hmm that was very
disrespectful for pulling that gun out
in front of you mmm-hmm
things could have happened I just want
to apologize to you myself I'm gonna go
apologize to your mother now and he was
my always my mother's friend that yeah
but what do you apologize never say no
no no no no
you're my hero yeah but you pulled the
gun on somebody and he was serious yeah
all those beatings him getting jumped
every night so I kind of I've asked him
once what happened to your hands three
[ __ ] him and even call them [ __ ]
somebody wanted me they jumped on me and
beat me that's right it was unsettled
like being gay was that sembly yeah then
and I became friends and we were friends
till about 1981 to my Robin and even
then he would he knew I would go to my
mother's grave so he would leave notes
at my mother's grave well I say I'm
gonna kill you oh my god I told this on
the I told the story in a kind of one of
this is not happening
yes that guy always stuck with me I feel
like you got some money good story oh no
we got like yeah but it's funny that I
just always one of my dearest friends
when I was 8 mm he was gay
yeah you know and he was [ __ ] chicks
like a [ __ ] really yeah he was
16 because in 1976 you just couldn't
come on Gaza in 1980
you just didn't come out of closet I
accepted you came out of the closet your
family would throw you out loud yeah
especially your Italian from Jersey yeah
you know it's like a girl from Jersey
dating a black guy you've done you can't
come to the neighborhood no more no they
won't respect you I'm sorry I'm not that
way but there are people that think yeah
but you weren't that way because you had
friends like I feel like it's the people
that don't have friends or like we don't
have a personal connection to a gay
person I have never I could tell you
looking you in the eye on Taylor's I've
had fifty to a hundred gay friends I was
involved with drugs mm-hmm and I never
had a gay man come to me come on to me
well even there's a joke like something
like sometimes while you're looking good
tonight Joey don't make me show my
friends to you yeah they like what my
friend used to say I had a gay acting
coach for a while uh-huh he would go up
my place they love bears like you he
would always say I don't get insulted by
that uh-huh it's if you grab my crotch
yeah you know what that I've never been
disrespected by a gay man you ever ever
ever at all I don't think anyone would
want to disrespect you though you have
that thing that kind of commands respect
well that energy won't respect you gotta
give respect yeah I have gay I have Rob
gay bands grab gay men's asses yeah guys
hand them put on my dick one time it's
not I'm raw but over the genes Eric I
would never do that just to break the
ice
yeah and they go crazy because they
expect a guy like me not to like them
yeah that's what they expect yeah I like
weak to reject them I would if I know
you're gay I will out those shoes you
know I on the plane and the store this
is as gay as it drew right I'll some
[ __ ] My Lai ya
yeah hairdo is magnificent today yes you
goofing on them but at the same time
they're loving it or showing except I
have no seen those shoes to cats because
we don't we don't expect it from you
know I would think people would think of
you like as a tough guy who's the best
hugger at the family store that's good
Mike there
nobody is you're better hugged in just a
month that's sir there's nobody when
Justin Martin hell I'll give me my back
brace my friend that can't be copping a
feel longer but I think jess is really
good influence on the guys at the store
you know like I don't
I've never really heard especially in my
world and I'm a dirty [ __ ] I've
never said I'm gonna need that [ __ ] to
mean you know I've never now war
brothers nobody gives a better hug than
Justin Martin damn and nobody was a
bigger comedy friend to me when I was on
drugs and your boy when I was having my
problem what he was there for me he was
clean for a long time yeah who's on my
upstairs Sunday night yeah that was a
time he was nap today eh yeah rain he
was struggling he was struggling and we
would talk on the phone yeah I'd love to
do with the come side [ __ ] with some men
my mother that raised me that to be like
hateful right no I love that I love that
[ __ ] your [ __ ] up
drag the Hudson County Park and [ __ ]
beat the [ __ ] up yeah they want to come
over and get the dick sucked by sixteen
year old boys who would beat them up
yeah I mean there might not even be a
way for you to answer this well you
saying we have a closed gay friend I've
always said gay friends do you think
it's a different experience for the gay
guys versus gay girls or is it similar
like you think it's differently I think
it's harder for I think it's harder for
gay men to get accepted
around straight men and I think straight
men have a give lesbians a little more
leeway I think it's changing and but I I
feel like I would get accepted by men
because there was no threat there you
know they're like oh it's just like it's
like a buddy
right where's this like some straight
men don't feel comfortable around Gaiman
I never thought about that yeah what was
that I'm sorry
just that she she feels like it's harder
for gay guys to get accepted rather than
like a lesbian like yeah I feel like I
feel like a lot of straight men aren't
as accepting of gay men there they're
like feel threatened or feel
uncomfortable but I think straight men
don't seem as intimidated by lesbians no
no with us yeah I've told you my mother
encouraged me to be friends to everybody
mm-hmm my stepfather it's not being a
role there was a gay man in that room
yeah yeah and I would not let a gay man
touch his head mm-hmm he wouldn't spit
on a gay guy but he wouldn't go out of
his way to make conversation him in his
inner his mental blah his beliefs you
know young he told me he was in Cuba you
were gay
yeah the payment would take you shark
hunting because it was like a shame oh
yeah
in the Latin community is really tough
you know some parents of a hundred
percent accepting right the one is the
revolutionary cute like if you watch
celeea she had a brother
uh-huh really dr. globe would killed
that little gay boy mm-hmm you know that
wasn't big now Cuba does what they do
whatever yeah my the general the two
generations before me they were raised
to be I walk into a barber shop there's
a gay guy I walk out yeah I didn't know
I would say I would ask them you're
embarrassing me I'm not gonna stand in
here with that [ __ ] yelling really
yeah really
so that's the thing yeah some people are
raised to that it's some people I look
at them as
yeah I have fun with them when I write
Joe you know I used to get drugs at
ramrods when I was 19 I used to go to on
games called ramrods a supersized three
floors of [ __ ] gay [ __ ] lesbians on
the second floor with lingerie
there were lesbians swapping spit
listening to like soft jazz oh yeah the
third floor was the people one fists up
there yeah which I never knew heating up
that floor oh that's what you get the
kid you gotta go to the third floor the
game of death the top floor to get the
goods
Aaron's ramming each other oh my god I
saw a guy giving a [ __ ] what that
update was a work of art did you learn
anything by watching no I watched him
whoa the guy was upside down that he was
blowing oh my god so all the blood was
in his head you suck somebody's dick in
their bloods in their head you're
digging got nowhere to go so this guy
was sucking his dick at the speed of
motion like a choo-choo train and he was
focused just looking at the guy's balls
he was yeah it was like he learned from
the rush yeah perfect throat usually you
see a Russian run they run perfect I was
impressed yeah yeah I'm gonna get a dick
sucker that's the way that nickel maybe
ten bucks whatever he's working $500 is
a gay guy would suck you big four small
five hours yeah a cute guy like yourself
ten no discuss what I'm gonna pick be
out when things get rough oh yeah oh
yeah there's a couple different
scenarios I'm gonna put up on that app
right there oh that's what I do from
KTLA met that guy Yeah right that's why
the dates
uh-huh that's all those [ __ ]
will kill you they'll cut your head and
put it in the refrigerator like Dahmer
hey jerk-off when you was going you
gotta be careful on line now they open
up your mouth in the freezer yeah are
you on any dating site I'm on the I'm on
tinder
my buddies on Grindr and that's it's
pretty intense
well yeah cuz they just want to [ __ ]
yeah they don't care at all you could
drop him off anywhere our friend uh-huh
he's gonna get out of the car anyway and
he's put siapa he presses a button he
gets like a single it's the time and
before you know the cars pulling up
before we make the corner those guys
have it down to a science
it's so interesting but that's cuz
there's no woman to pump the brakes you
got two dudes just horny [ __ ] just
like let's get to it
it's the woman who's always like oh wait
wait how did you meet your fiancé I met
her at gay pride in Chicago
really yeah we were I was there just
hanging out and she was there we had
mutual friends and we just started
talking and as lesbians do we've been
together ever since
now you have you had exes have you have
a couple axes yeah I mean I definitely
dated people before her I call you up
and say you're [ __ ] big-time now I
bet they pop up here and there for sure
because they want to be friends with me
still and not some of them I don't want
to be friends of that and some of them I
would am friends with I just don't see
them very much but you know you
definitely have those people who because
I'm on television or whatever they think
I'm successful they are trying to
continue to be in my orbit but you know
you just let that I mean cuz I'm engaged
now like we were together three and a
half years like I know there are
lesbians who are friends with their exes
but I'm just kind of like I'm just
living them up like why you know like
I've got my fiancee we're living our
life and I don't I have a lot of friends
I don't need to necessarily go hang out
with my exes you know maybe get married
what is it date what we don't have a
date but probably probably next year
tell me why your ideal wedding well I
don't want that traditional ceremony you
know I don't want to like be in it
walking being a lot of churches they
don't allow it
fucking-a voice I want to pee
[ __ ] like that I don't want more I
think I won't like the ceremony part to
be like how a rehearsal dinner would be
like just dinner with my friends and
family and get married in front of like
20 people but I want a big party I don't
I only care about a big celebration so
the wedding well I would invite people
to would just be like what the reception
would be at a wedding but without all
this is good yeah everybody's doing in
Carolina we should call here yeah but
you're 16 years and what are you [ __ ]
poor folks are doing North Carolina they
come out here she's just getting married
in North Carolina [ __ ] nice and the
home the Rocky Mountain they chase me
with a Bible out of there no people my
hometown are really cool about it but I
just all my friends are here I don't
want to make a bunch of people have to
fly to North Carolina you know so it's
easier for my family to come here I
don't know where we'll get married I
mean it's everything so expensive but
I'm really hoping Martha Stewart will
just throw me a wedding those fake
chapels you're going in you can put the
set that's why I got married really they
have a chapel on cold water though have
little pictures Elvis put a different
screen the Grand Canyon and you [ __ ]
[ __ ] I rented out the hall at the
Hollywood Bowl oh by the Wednesday the
Hollywood Bowl yes before you get the
Hollywood Bowl down the corner it's like
60 people but there's rocks behind it
yeah we'll go outside and smoke and I
got married 2009 okay and I got married
on wolf [ __ ] uh-huh we picked up fried
pork chunks and loco chinito pastrami
from Wang is the best [ __ ] which is
in town and we picked up a hundred
pieces of fried chicken from rouse they
cook the freshness with my wife in the
south
yeah and no gifts allowed yeah I didn't
want to give someone No
you feel stressful right right dress how
you want
uh-huh you can't come it's cool yeah and
it was one of the best weddings that
have a went that we have a little music
dance that kind of cake there you go and
I don't I don't like weddings or the
drama no I don't want a long boring
drawn-out thing yeah I'm happy you got
out of here today know that you were a
writer and all that yeah I it means a
lot to get to do this cuz you know it's
the coming up at the Comedy Store I was
I'm a little shy like people don't know
that about me because I play crazy
characters but I'm a little shy so when
I was coming up at the store I had a
tendency to sort of be more of the
observer I wouldn't kind of be in the
corner watching people and I'm friends
with plenty of stand-ups but I didn't
really put myself out there in a way
that everybody knows each other so well
and I would have liked nice individual
relationships with stand-ups but I never
felt like I was like one of the one of
the guys or one of the crew but like the
stand-ups have been so nice to me
and in the last couple years especially
I've really reached out to me and I've
really just appreciate people I don't
know the other stand-ups showing me love
and show me respect it means it means a
lot to me you know how tough it is in
the stand-up business to get men's
respect yeah the idea you me together
suck our dick to the next game yeah you
have to do something right when I look
at you I look at my eyes on everybody I
give you all the same respect I have a
six-year-old hmm what happens if my
[ __ ] little [ __ ] here once again
the comic right you know there's only a
[ __ ] we'd get the comedy right what if
my little [ __ ] wants to get into
comedy I want her to get the same
respect I give you but I get Whitney but
I give any other woman comics Arianna
doesn't matter you've earned the respect
you've gun that out there with men
you know my mother was one of you know
not a lesbian mother was one of you yeah
yeah that you walked into a room with
you oh I'm here
if you fold you were done yeah can't
show us your fear yeah that's very tough
for a woman I had a birthday party a
couple weeks ago I invited mostly men
couple girls I did that for a reason
so my daughter could feel comfortable
mm-hmm around the group of men she
learns how to have confidence she learns
how to compose herself right oh you shut
the [ __ ] up either tell me to shut the
[ __ ] up you shut the [ __ ] off yeah when
you have a woman that knows how to say
that cuz a guy will say you don't know
what you're talking about the [ __ ] up no
[ __ ] you shut the [ __ ] up
and what what [ __ ] punch in his
head with his bottle yeah and that's how
you get respect from me yeah men walk
out of room Lord [ __ ] I'm never saying
that before chili again you don't I
don't get it by our union and crying at
the end of the conversation you don't
get it that's when we fought with you I
guess I should give thanks to my two
older brothers for yes there's no
tougher people in the world own Irish
sister when my brother yeah because
we've been they put your hand on top of
cigarette smoke in there Irish brothers
do all they said was a kid they would
like trying to get me to come towards
the steps to fall down the steps a be
like come here girl like you're a little
[ __ ] but I guess it doesn't make you
tougher but I just yeah I mean I've had
a lot of really great stand ups be
really good to me bill burr has been
like one of the best dudes to me a lot
it's just so much respect from the guy
to the comedy school we see no one's
faking I know he's down there
pulling down her shirt just show me
cleavage yeah and I know who's up there
oh I'm going to show you some titties
all the way where you performing this
week I'm in London oh so we have a lot
of family we have a lot of church
come to Tsavo Tacoma Washington Kansas
City st. Louis Columbia Missouri all
those are in Missouri and Houston Texas
so come out to a show in Houston I will
be in Houston this yes fortune thank you
thanks for being on the show
[ __ ] yes it will love you more
than me
Houston I'm coming and I think all the
shows are sold out a four out of five is
sold out so get your [ __ ] together it's
all over but the shouting I'll be there
this weekend all right and now for a
word from our sponsors all right I want
to thank fortune Finster I want to thank
the [ __ ] [ __ ] extraordinary
and I want to thank you guys from Meghan
it's a beautiful [ __ ] day to be alive
it's gonna be a great week Monday I'm
going to Houston but the Church of
what's happening now is brought to you
by manscape let me tell you some time to
time I get a little H is down there and
before I go on the road I know it's
because I don't condition my [ __ ]
pubes and sometimes the pubes get dry
and I get it she down there so I just
had my wife [ __ ] trimming my nutsack
with a conventional [ __ ] razor you
don't know what fear factor is do you
have somebody trimming your [ __ ]
razors and you're looking up begging
that nothing bad happens to you that all
ends to the Uncle Joe you got something
for you manscaped
you get it done without the pain and the
anxiety they got precision tools for the
family [ __ ] good news man manscaped
has redesigned the electric razor the
lawn mower 2.0 is their handheld razor
with skin-safe technology so it will
Nick or snag your nutsack or if your
uncircumcised like me that little
[ __ ] wind [ __ ] tunnel at the
Elliot dick this bad boy will leave you
clean smooth and pain-free most
importantly anxiety-free plus it's
recharge more and easy to hold you can
take it on the road with you so you can
get into all the nooks and crannies you
follow me and I got a classic safety
razor called the plow that will give you
a smooth shave without the humps and
bumps listen if you want to trim your
[ __ ] take it upon yourself and you
know what they say if you trim the
hedges the tree looks taller you follow
me so what the [ __ ] are you waiting for
stop [ __ ] around your dick looks like
a [ __ ] you know I got hit with a
hammer and a thousand other things trim
it making
look nice you ever go to a nice
restaurant they give me like a slice
orange with the eggs they make the dish
look nice the food tastes like [ __ ] you
follow me but they make it look nice I
want you to have that area nice so the
perfect package comes with a lawnmower
and the plow plus the crop preserver
especially formulated anti shaving
deodorant so your balls don't stink
trust me this thing works tremendous
plus they got the Reviver spritz that
tones and refreshes your nutsack plus
your little anal area there to keep your
nuts cool now the church family gets 20%
off your first order when you use promo
code church in manscaped
DOM and if you're under the perfect
package don't throw in a free travel bag
when you use promo code Church that's
manscape calm use promo code church for
20% off your first order like I said
it's Monday
wash your nutsack now after you got your
area all cleaned and everything listen
you got to get everything together I
know there's people got little problems
out there for all different reasons
sexual performance issues are more
common than what you think
one in four guys suffer from Edie but it
could be treated over 25% of new EB
cases are coming from men under 40 why
do men turn to weird solutions or do
nothing when they can instead turn to
medicine in science because getting
older sometimes means certain parts of
the body might not be working like they
should they start rubbing that engine up
again and and with edie treatment for
hymns you'll be back go to for hymns
calm a one-stop shop for hair loss skin
care and sexual wellness for men listen
to me don't get deferred by online
sketchy marketplaces for hymns provides
convenient access to US doctors online
and real medicines dispensed from
American pharmacies all right slide on
the film the active ingredient in viagra
can be prescribed for men online and
delivered right to your door it's comple
tlie confidential and discreet nobody
knows nuttin you don't gotta bump into
the secretary you know the nurse at the
[ __ ] supermarket no more awkward
in-person doctor visits along pharmacy
line you save hours by going to forums
calm
bring your best means performing your
best it's hard made easy this has been
featured in GQ men's health ask why and
Playboy to name a few so what I'm gonna
do for you is this you don't need to
suffer from Edie or hair loss plenty of
that stuff you got a nip nip it in the
bud and natural for him as does do me a
favor this first month because your
church family you got it for five bucks
will get you started for five hours
while supplies last and subject to
doctor approval
restrictions apply so see the website
for full details this could cost you
hundreds if you went to a doctor or
pharmacy go to forums calm slash Church
that's for hymns knock calm slash right
now go to the website you know you
suffering from this go to that website
go to four hymns that time and press in
church on the way out I'm gonna give you
the first month for five hours that's
how long people joy takes carry on a
Monday morning again I want to thank for
hymns calm I want to thank manscape calm
I want to thank fortune I want to thank
the Christ killer but I want to thank
you [ __ ] for letting me come
into your life on a Monday morning I'll
love you guys
have a great week Houston see you
Thursday night [ __ ] take this
merely a little Tony Bennett Davies
[ __ ]